Gretchen Whitmer has spent most of her
working life in the grubby small-bore
confines of Michigan State politics that
is not a training ground for excellence
so when she was elected governor a
little over a year and a half ago nobody
expected that Whitmer would suddenly
morph into a wise and inspired chief
executive and indeed she hasn't when the
krona virus hit Michigan in force last
month Whitmer had no clue what to do so
she responded with a mixture of comical
ineptitude and a weird kind of arbitrary
fascism she banned the sale of carpets
and paint and potted plants she told
people they couldn't fish or go to
church or drive alone to their own homes
but at the same time Whitmer kept liquor
stores weed shops and lotto kiosks open
because and this was purely an
epidemiological matter in the interests
of the public health those were
essential services quote they also
happened to provide massive tax revenue
to her government the whole thing was
ridiculous it was just a matter of time
before the people suffering under this
insanity said something about it and
yesterday they did thousands of Michigan
residents drove to the state capitol in
Lansing to express their displeasure
they didn't hurt anyone while they were
there they did it peacefully as is there
in trying right under the American
Constitution the governor Whitmer didn't
like this in fact she was outraged if
there's one thing Gretchen Whitmer
doesn't care for it's civil disobedience
especially when it's aimed at her is
Whitmer I explained yesterday
complaining about her decisions could
kill people you know when people are
flying the Confederate flag and untold
numbers who gassed up on the way here or
grabbed a bite on the way home we know
that this rally endangered people when
you disagree with Gretchen Whitmer you
endanger the public that's the new
standard in Michigan Debbie Dingell
supports that standard Dingell is a
longtime GM lobbyist a car lobbyist who
inherited her congressional seat from
her husband who in turn inherited it
from his father a Dingell has
represented Michigan in the US House of
Representatives continuously for 88
years since 1932 the family
businesses politics but it's really a
form of monarchy so you won't be
surprised to learn that Debbie Dingell
is very popular socially in Washington
she shares with her neighbors they're an
undisguised loathing for the people of
Michigan she expressed that contempt
this morning on NBC what happened
yesterday was inexcusable people did not
have mass they didn't have gloves they
did not distance himself
they had Confederate flag swastikas they
blocked an ambulance trying to get to a
hospital
breaking hate and fear into a time that
is already full of fear and anxiety it's
just unacceptable there were people
barehanded candy candy the children what
they did was to help spread this disease
around the state more most likely not
contribute to the mitigation and it just
made me sad Oh sad Debbie Dingell is sad
she sad that people are expressing
inconvenient political beliefs when they
should be drinking alone at home or
obediently buying more state sponsored
lotto tickets why can't they hit
Michigan's entirely essential weed
stores and numb out as their benevolent
leader Gretchen solidifies her control
over their lives why don't have to
complain all the time saying unapproved
things is racist it inspires fear and
hate stop it right now you proles how
dare you fire up a bowl and accept your
fate